اهلا بكم نبدا اذا من تطورات حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا فقد اعلنت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه وجهت سبعين
ضربا للاراضي الاوكرانيه بصواريخ من الجو
والبحر بمسيره شاهد خلال الليله وقال
الرئيس الاوكراني
مركزا لنقل الدم في بلده كوبيانسك شرقي
ونشر صوره قال انها لعمال انقاذ امام
المنشاه المستهدفه
هذا وقال ايضا الرئيس الاوكراني الضرب
الروسيه طالت مصنع طائرات جنوب شرقي
اوكرانيا
استهدف هجوم صاروخي روسي اخر بلدنا اليوم
استخدمت فيه صواريخ كينج وكاليبر لضرب
مصنع موتور سيتش ومنطقه
اسقطنا بعض الصواريخ بفضل جنود الدفاع
الجوي لكن بغض النظر عن عدد الهجمات
الروسيه فانها لن تقدم للعدو شيئا مع ذلك
سنحمي الحريه لاوكرانيا ولشعبنا ولم
يستبدل القانون الدولي بالارهاب الروسي او
بالازمات او باي ترهيب